ok my name is Ron adopts I'm also from
pivotal I'm also data scientists and
today I'm actually going to present you
a live demo of a connected car prototype
we build if it actually works I think it
will be one of the most exciting talks
here at PI data if it works and it's
certainly the only talk that will have
potential for bodily harm and
manslaughter I imagine yeah I want you
to be introducing pivotal alex has
already done so so I'll just switch
ahead everything i'll be presenting
today is actually available as open open
source code so i'll be sharing this deck
later on and you can download all the
code if you have any questions please do
not hesitate to ask them so how did this
project come about so we did a really
really cool customer project and it had
written all the great aspects of a iot
peyote project we had the ingestion of a
lot of fast data we had a not large
number of of clients in the network and
we had some real time data science on a
displayed on a dashboard but sadly this
was covered by an ironclad NDA so there
was no no way we can show this so we got
thinking what can we do about this and
we came up with the connected car it's
everybody is familiar with a car it's a
very relatable concept and the pieces
they're really all the same so we have
the same technology as in this client
project we using spring XD for data
ingestion and streaming I'll talk more
about that later we use Hadoop for
storage we use Python for the data
analytics part and we used a gem fire
which is also open source now as project
geode as a as a data cache layer which
is a in memory database by the way and
we're using HTML and JavaScript for the
dashboard so we came up with two two use
cases for this one is to predict the
destination of the driver based on
his historical driving behavior in real
time and a sentient the sentient use
case is so once we've actually predicted
that destination will be able to very
accurately predict the range the the
remaining range of that particular fill
of gas so a quick architectural overview
we start with the car the data is made
available via the obd2 port of the car
every car since the 1990s has this port
you can plug Bluetooth obd2 dongle in
this port and we then built an iOS app
we called it Herbie that connects to
this bluetooth dongle and streams the
data streams the data to server in the
cloud coming off of the car and from
there we are able to display our results
on a dashboard so let's go to the live
demo part of this talk now I really do
hope we can get a stable connection
enough of you have actually gotten off
the Wi-Fi so i can get a decent
connection to my colleague here okay
let's try this again okay give him a
ring here let's try facetime this time
okay hello fellas hello oh it's not
looking good think I'll try skype one
more time otherwise you will just have
to drive without a video feed I'm afraid
if we can make this work I'll try skype
maybe I can also tether but I'm not
getting a good network in here let's
give skype another gone again oh hello
Ferris yes yes now we can finally hear
you the video the video is very very
spotty but we can hear you okay yes yes
please go ahead cool so uh but it's good
that's part of the this is not sorry
Ferris the connection is this the
connection is oh there are no known
order well the connection is very the
connection is fairly horrible actually I
I believe it would be good if you just
if you just started driving we can
hardly hear you yeah well we need a we
need a yeah I'm connected to beta house
in no space was much slower but we can
yes okay
okay we're better houseguests now is it
this time better yes it's it's a little
better okay doesn't work i still have
yeah i'll try i'll try the phone let's
try the phone i'll put him on
speakerphone let's see if that works no
there's no network cable around here we
have a dashboard here I love Ferris yeah
does the internet the internet is too
slow so maybe we can talk to you on the
phone I'm not sure I'm not sure oh yeah
good idea yes okay pluck you in here now
in the main thing here please go ahead
again yes car to the back in and yeah I
think I'm gonna just move on and yeah
just start just gets me yeah
so by now you should be able to see some
some data presented let me reload the
page here I don't give us a second
please we have no no let me try
different yes now now we're getting some
yes okay why don't you wrap up your car
so we can see that we're getting some
real time data so so you can see the RP
every display yes give us 3,000 3,000
rpms yes this will make the Greens happy
okay it's looking good we're getting
some real time data I was really
starting to worry okay okay okay why
don't you why don't you tell us where
you want to go today so well I'm here
right now at pencil back that starts the
place i live and yeah I have many
destinations I could go to today so
basically if I want to be creative I
could go as a place called psycho walls
you may know that and work on my
business ideas if I want to relax I
could go to folks bar for instance which
is also not far away from here there is
the beta house you know might not my
know that place where I can go and
develop my locations and tackle a bit
and of course I there's also other
locations such as the weekends where I
can party with tourists and if I want to
go really hard to the real bird install
I could go to places such as Birkin or
Watergate so these are my destinations
today excellent
okay so yep let's get started then
please do yeah we can no not yet start
start are you okay there's some traffic
at Sur as will do them yes okay so so in
the meantime I'll explain yeah oh okay
so yeah finally is taking off so this is
all in real time it's not pre recorded
as you can see as you as you probably
believe me as so much has gone wrong
this is all I guess it's all real time
data so let me explain the dashboard a
little bit it actually supports multiple
vehicles so up here you can support you
can select the window the vehicle
identification number of that car so at
the moment we're only following one car
here the dashboard it's only displaying
a subset of the data we're getting from
the obd2 port you can see you to speed
the RPM we have a coolant temperature
we're also getting the we're also
getting the fuel level of the car but
them really the more interesting pain
here is this one where we can see wonder
the predicted range so how much longer
can the car actually go and the most
interesting piece here is we have
actually all these possible destinations
Pharaoh's told us about and we get a
probability distribution over these
destinations here that gets updated
every second so as he's driving in real
time these probabilities they get
updated out to tell you more about that
later how these models actually work
there they're all implemented in Python
so yeah at the moment the model believes
is he's going with fifty nine percent
probability to Santo balls for example
okay
so let me switch back here to the
presentation and talk a little bit more
about the technical specifics how all
this works okay mmm Saul does all this
work right we start in the car since the
end of the 90s every car comes with a
ovd to port it sends for on-board
diagnostics port you can plug a dongle
into it and then then you can get a
sensor data off of the car in 200
millisecond intervals you can get rpm
you can get speed you can get things
like the mass air flow rate the
temperature of various places in the
engine and so on now we thought how can
we get this data off of the car we had
our colleagues at pivotal labs who focus
on app development develop a mobile app
for us we call it Herbie and this app is
able to connect to the bluetooth dongle
and stream data off of the car into a
server in the cloud and we also enrich
the data with GPS data from the phone
acceleration data and enter bearing so
not only our streaming data off of the
car but also off the phone and we use
the serial network to stream it into the
cloud this is a oh this is very horrible
horrible horrible
you can't see anything can you no no
okay well this is a just in theory is
adjacent blob of the data we're getting
pretend pretend it's there oh okay so
the way this works is we're sending the
data by TCP sockets over bluetooth to
the app and then via HTTP POST over
cellular to the server in the cloud and
from there to the dashboard so how does
the server how does the software on the
server look like we're using spring XD
which stands for extreme data it's an
open source project it comes from a
spring team but it has very little to do
with Java so you don't need to use job
don't need to know Java to use this it
actually supports Tyson processors which
we're using it's a really really cool
project for streaming data analysis and
I really encourage you to have a look
you can just brew install it if you have
a riot app and it works out of the box
it's a very interesting project so let's
talk a little bit about spring XD in the
context of this project we are ingesting
the data into spring XD and we're
storing it both in Hadoop and in gemfire
so so we're basically breaking up the
stream and storing it in two places
gemfire for the real time part and
hadoop for later the for the batch
analytics right gemfire is then able to
feed this dashboard and spring XD
handles the data ingestion the data
orchestration it handles the data
extraction and the real time analytics
part now a spring XD has a distributed
runtime so it can run on multiple
servers and it scales really well we've
we've done this at the client it scales
to thousands and thousands of vehicle
streaming a large large amounts of data
every saint and it has a streaming and a
batch engine you can control spring XD
via a console which you can also not see
here and and but it has a dashboard as
well so you can get it you get a sort of
a graphical user interface you can use
now a spring XD is modeled after the
unique shell so for example here this is
a simpler version of what we're actually
using so you have an HTTP source then
you have a pipe it's like unix pipe then
you apply a filter to it so in this case
we're cleaning up the data a bit
managing it slightly then we are
enriching the data from the with the
data from the cell phone and then we can
pipe it to some shell module in our case
we're using Python for the analytics and
then we save the results on HDFS for
later analysis so this is simplified
pipeline on how this would look like
what you can also do but you can also do
is you can create something called taps
taps come from wiretapping what our
friends at the NSA NSA do so you can
actually break up a stream and send it
to multiple places so in our example
like i mentioned we're saving the data
in HDFS but we also want to do some real
time stuff like display it and so on so
what we do here is we create the step
here with this sign and we're able to
then also send it to gemfire instead of
just HDFS which was our catch cash layer
okay shall we check in with Ferris and
see how he's doing Ferris are you still
there let's see where you are where you
heading to excellent let's let's have a
look where your oh okay so you're you're
almost at alexanderplatz so the model
the model here believes now there's a
high problem well forty forty seven
percent probability of him going to
going to the weekend club what's
interesting what you can see here so
destination number two here oh oh oh the
dough it went here again odds cutting
off the side of the screen okay sorry
about that also the other side here okay
not 16 29 anyway okay so what's
interesting here the model correctly
inferred that he's driven past these two
destinations here the destination number
two and destination number one which was
the folks park and sank over Hans so
this has become these have become very
unlikely so if we look now here
destination number two is at zero
percent and destination number one is
that one percent and so now it also just
dropped to zero so the model quite
correctly inferred that if you would
have driven to it either of these two
destinations then he would have taken a
different road earlier on now now only
these these destinations are still in
play at the moment for some reason the
model believes that is very likely to go
to a weekend club which uh oh yeah I
guess Ferris likes to party okay let's
go back to the presentation it must be
said we recorded these journeys
yesterday so this is all in real
historical data and the more journeys
you record the more accurate the model
become since it's a it's a little bit
jumpy because we don't have that many
drives of course but just for the for
this presentation we recorded some some
drives in this area okay so let's get
back here okay so uh so the way this
works is the data comes in via HTTP from
the app we apply some transformers to it
and then we stream it into the pious and
so de Pisan part has some models and
these models generate the predictions
for the destination and the range yeah
and the output gets stored in two places
one is HDFS and what is the gem file tab
to be displayed on real time on the
dashboard via the REST API now the
interesting part is we train the models
in PI spark so this is the pious an API
of spark which is sitting on top of a
tube and we periodically train these
models and then the models from from PI
spark here they get sent back in
to the Python process of the Pisan
processes using an updated model and all
these and all these parts in green we
had to code something for but all the
other parts actually spring XD handle
these out of the box for the Hadoop part
for gemfire tab and for although other
connections we had to write zero code so
this is all handled by spring fire by
spring XD which i think is it that's why
it's a really interesting project let's
talk a bit about the data science so how
does the data science part of this work
the first use case is predicting the
journey and the second one is predicting
the range based off of the journey
prediction let's define a journey what
is the journey a journey starts the
moment you switch on your car and it
ends once you switch it off again so if
you drive safe from home to work that
that I consider that one journey we're
basically trying to predict whether you
are on that journey so how does this
work by collecting lots of historic data
we're able to generate a sort of driving
behavior fingerprint of these kinds of
journeys and so given this fingerprint
we are able to then in then all this all
looks very horrible then we can compare
this fingerprint to your current drive
and see which which which journey is the
most likely journey that you're on now
so we can actually only predict journey
journeys you have been on previously we
don't predict new journeys how does
these how do these journeys look like
for example these are some other
journeys we've recorded in Berlin so for
example here this is this is one journey
in one color then we have another
journey here another journey in green
another one in blue and now we are
actually we actually have a pipeline of
three models to make all this work so
the first step is to generate journey
clusters because if you just store this
store this data in HDFS there's really
no way
at all we can say to hdfs okay give me
all the journeys from work to the gym
for example it will just not know which
which of these journeys to get so to be
able to give this sort of semantic
meaning to our journey we we run a
clustering algorithm of it on on all the
journeys on all the recorded journeys so
we're then able to extract a given a
given journey cluster and this looks
like this so here we have a map of
Berlin again and this for example is a
journey cluster start and this is a
journey cluster end we use k-means on
these models and we used k-means to to
model this and it works works
surprisingly well out of the box and it
is able to identify although all the
relevant journey clusters and once we
have these clusters these surface labels
to the supervised learning models
downstream and so once we've generated
these labels we will then have a second
model that generates an initial
prediction the moment you turn on your
car because if you think about it all
the sensor data that is coming off of
this obd2 port the moment you turn on
the cards more or less always going to
be the same sort carries very little
information we can predict where you're
going but we're actually using the time
of day day of the week and you're
starting GPS coordinates to generate a
good initial prediction of where you're
going so for example a good example
would be if you are at home and it's a
weekday and it's the morning you're very
and you start your car it's very likely
that you will be driving to work
probably so that would be a good initial
guess for a model to make so that's
exactly what we do and for example here
for the data we record it we can see the
problem the probability of driving from
home to work so on the y axis we have
the probability and on x axis system if
it's a minute of the day and you can see
that in the morning the probability of
the model is very high that your your
driving to work and then it drops during
the day that is almost zero the opposite
is true from for driving from work to
home and the probability then suddenly
starts rising in the evening and based
on this this prediction we're then able
able to predict the range so we can say
okay given that you're going to work we
know how you behaved on this particular
journey previously how much fuel you use
we can then pretty accurately say okay
you have that much range man it's not so
important for petrol cars but for
electric cars it becomes extremely
important and the third step of this is
that we update the model this initial
prediction we updated in real time and
and we do so by by comparing all the
sensor data that streams into all the
other journeys or the other journey
clusters that we have labeled and then
we assign a probability distribution
over these journey clusters so that is
what we actually see on a desk part so
this initial prediction gets slowly
faded out and the online predictions
become more and more important as more
sensor data streams in this is an
example of such a prediction here again
you can already see it but what you get
here is basically this is just one
prediction err it gives you the end
location coordinates of that prediction
how much how much fuel you used on these
type of journeys previously and the
probability okay so let's recap the
architecture here we start with a phone
the data streams into spring XD we
persist this data into a dupe we use
spark a spark for batch training and
then we push these models back into
spring xtina spiceland process where
they get evaluated in real time and we
push the results out back out to the
dashboard
so how do we actually use a spark we
don't use ml lip but we use spark to
drive parallel scikit-learn processes we
do this because because we don't
actually have one very big model where
ml lip would be suitable but we have
many smaller models because for each car
for each vehicle we have a different
model so we can do this in dat apparel
and we just we just use spark to drive
scikit-learn and we don't use spark
streaming excuse me was there question
no ok ok when we don't use spark
streaming because Park streaming just
supports mini batches it doesn't support
real true real-time streaming use cases
like this one and then we push the
results back out onto the dashboard
let's quickly check here where Ferris is
currently and see how the models how the
models are doing in if the internet
would have worked nicely we would have
gotten some some real time video feeds
of course ok so now we can see that
Ferris here just crossing the river spey
and what we can also see hello what did
you say oh that's wonderful yes and
what's interesting here so the model has
correctly excluded destination number
for weekend where where pharaohs goes to
dance and meet tourists so here this
this this destination has gone to zero
and even though yesterday we only
recorded a few drives the models still
be is still able to fairly accurately
produce these estimates as we can see
and now the only two possible
destinations the model still considers
likely is beta house actually where we
are here destination zero and
destination number five which is the
watergate club here probably maybe
Ferris wants to go to after our so yeah
we can see them approaching here and as
he approaches here a beta house or or
the weekend oh sorry or Watergate we
should see either of these destinations
also dropping 20 and then the
probability
of the last remaining destination should
go to one hundred percent and the more
data we actually collect the more likely
and the more accurate these models will
become and so let's just watch them a
little more because this is quite an
interesting point here we can see a way
is actually going to know which
destination will pan out we can see that
now Watergate the destination number
five here is dropping in probability
whereas beta house is actually rising in
probability now we can see that this the
model is actually predicting a beta
house was almost now one hundred percent
probability and this is all happening in
real time is not pre-recorded there's a
real machine learning model and yeah
okay we can so it looks like Ferris is
actually going to beta us yes pharaohs
were you planning this all along why why
why didn't you tell me about this Oh
fantastic okay I'll do that I'll reserve
a beer for you we go we've got the
Watergate later okay for us see you see
you in a little bit okay so we can
actually sees he's gotten to a beta
house and the model are corrected
predicted it correctly now let me switch
back to the presentation how am i doing
in x 50 50 okay got a couple of minutes
right and i we stream this to the
dashboard right and how does the
dashboard work right it uses gemfire as
an in-memory database is a cash-back end
we we talked to the dashboard talks to
gem file via is rest api we may be
generated the dashboard with your man
and angularjs and all this architecture
really really scales so for this client
project which was under NDA we actually
had around 100,000
a 100,000 devices all streaming data as
there was millions of messages per
minute and and we've got permitted over
100 gigabytes so this is this is a
framework that can really really scale
but there's also some issues with with
Internet of Things so one was one huge
issue issue is compatibility every car
vendor implements this obd2 standard
slightly different so for every car
we've done this with there were some
data problem so we we we had to adapt
the whole thing again and then create
some exceptions so it's really not
standardized at all and i think this
also applies to other areas of iot you
have this in a connected home you have
this in a lot of different areas that
really devices they just thought there's
no standard for anything that's a big
challenge and also connectivity you
don't always you don't always have very
good cellular reception data throughput
can be expensive there's there are also
security and privacy concerns so
especially in Germany it was fine for us
to record this data and experiment will
experiment with it but if we recorded
everybody's data we had to really be
concerned is it secure is it is it is it
not accessible by any malicious
intruders so yeah let's let's look a bit
into the future one step we're working
on is deploying this on Cloud Foundry
it's our platform our platform as a
service which alex introduced in the
last talked briefly recap it's it's
something like Heroku except you can
host it yourself if you want to
on-premise and it's also open source
it's governed by a foundation and its
really it's aspiring to be the operating
system of the cloud and you can push
apps to it you can scale apps seamlessly
and we really want to port this demo to
work on Cloud Foundry to be able to
scale and deploy it even better
some additional use cases we're working
on and thinking about our one fleet
management so as the scales to thousands
of thousands of cars it can be used for
fleet of cars or trucks to be able to
monitor them apply predictive
maintenance to these to this fleet see
the status of the fleet are there any
error codes and so on coming from the
engines and this then can be used for
predictive maintenance for example
another area is accident assistance so
we can also sense of course if there's a
prop stop or damage to the car it's also
possible to alert the ok Ferris hang up
on me another happens very often oh say
hello to Ferris he made it I Ferris yes
ok and that's actually perfect timing
because now I'm on to questions any
questions yes please no it doesn't know
about her oh yeah sorry I'm so the
question was how does the moat does the
model know about the road network and
the answer is no it does not the way it
works is for the initial prediction and
the online predictions on a prediction
we use when the data is streaming in we
use the random forest algorithm and the
random forest algorithm if you feed it
GPS data is actually able to to sort of
bisect the map quite well and build its
own sort of understanding of a road net
of a road network so this is but it has
no explicit knowledge of the road
network known yeah real
data is also very use case we're
thinking about although we have to
remember this is a this is not supposed
to be a product but a technical demo for
us also there's some some limitations to
the to the features in time we can can
spend of it okay yes please okay I'll
repeat the question so tomorrow as a
talk about spark but what is my
experience with spark so our team we've
we've started using spark recently quite
a bit it's a very interesting technology
but it's still somewhat immature
especially the Python API it produces
some out of memory errors sometimes and
on operations it shouldn't like joins
for example so so it can be a little bit
a bit of finicky to tune all the
parameters and so on there's another
very interesting project here in Berlin
called Apache fling which is supposed to
solve this memory issue because it's it
has it they wrote their own memory
manager we're very curious to try this
out as well it's a direct competitor to
spark and there and and fling also
supports or real streaming as opposed to
just mini batches so yeah but it's still
also very immature project so we'll see
any more questions ok hi i'm interested
for knowing like what kind of features
did you also consider for the
destination prediction task i see that
you're using these the schedules and the
gps coordinates and anything else that
you thought about or that might have
worked or yes so the question is what
other features did we think about so
besides all sensor data we are getting
from from the car and the gps state and
acceleration data from the phone
what would really be of course
interesting is to do something like
Google now put in calendar entries and
so on get other metadata put pulling
weather data pulling traffic data
pulling peoples peoples task risk or
something like this run text mining
honor to get more external data than
just a data from the car but we've done
sort of a self experiment and then
played around this a bit with ourselves
and the models actually people people
are animals of habit and they usually go
on the same routes and so the model is
actually quite good at predicting where
you're going to go okay we have time for
one more question it's actually created
um you mentioned that you are having a
model / driver or per car yes why not
just aggregating and using it basically
it ma makes of the car or drivers as a
as a feature because every because we
really recreate this unique fingerprints
off driver behavior to compare this to
and people behave different or different
routes to different destinations so I
think we'll lose a lot of information if
we just aggregated everybody into one
model I not really because you have the
feature you can have the feature you
know who's driving you know the mark of
the make of the car etc because at the
end of the same rules right yeah that is
there is somewhat true you can you can
have a global model but then also the
number of destinations of course
increases massively and it also becomes
a lot more complex but it's definitely
something we could think about all right
let's thank the speaker once again
you
you